Once I understand who my archetypes or persona is, the next thing I want to figure out
is how do I get them in to this funnel.
Regardless of whether it's web or mobile, I need to somehow figure out
how to get the interest of my customer archetypes--Dave in the major urban area
or Sally in the Midwest or someone in China or India.
How do I get them interested, and there are two types of ways to create demand.
The first set of things are paid demand creation activities.
Fancy word for saying--I'm going to pay somebody to get your interest.
First people I might want to pay is the public relations agency.
I might pay them a certain fee per month to help get stories about my products
and or my company in newspapers or in blogs or in tech journals, etc.
And so hiring a PR agency is a paid demand creation activities.
Another common paid activity is advertising. What kind of advertising?
Well, it depends what my archetype reads.
If they read a blog, I want somehow get either keywords or better ads or something in the blog.
If they read newspapers, tech journals, or listen to radio or television,
that is I want to match my demand creation activities to what I know about my archetype.
I'm not just going to randomly do this.
I'm actually going to try to match what I know to what I'm going to pay for.
Next thing could be trade shows. In some industries, people still physically go to trade shows.
Have booths, walk the aisles, meet people.
Maybe I should be in one and have a booth and maybe I'll find out my archetypes don't even care,
and by the way, just as inside, you might also want to be worried about whether your partner show up.
Maybe they show up at trade shows.
The other thing is that I might find out that such trade shows or webinars might be interesting
or I just might want to be sending them e-mail or direct mail.
US post office or post offices in other countries are still happy to carry your advertising.
Though this become less and less effective the more and more people are on the web,
and then finally search engine marketing, Google ads or Facebook ads, etc.
are now just a standard way to pay for demand creation activities
regardless of whether it's a physical channel or a mobile channel.
All of these activities are designed to feed the sales model.
The demand creation funnel is going to fed by these things you do.